what was the first question Tarantino
movie that you watched I think it was
pulp fiction I think it was but very
close to the same time I watched true
romance and linked them you know as the
screenwriter a Tarantino being the
screenwriter and true romance really
knocked me out like pulp fiction
obviously did for the obvious reasons
that everybody else kind of feels you
know it was like this new voice and if
you miss Reservoir Dogs and a lot of
people came to Reservoir Dogs through
pulp fiction
and I'm one of those but also true
romance so those two together I was like
wow Mia Wallace and Alabama Worley like
I was just yeah I was knocked out by
those gals you know what about Kevin
Smith too if you're growing up on the
East Coast oh yeah okay so yeah so so
sort of this whole like indie film night
days and rising yeah and then link later
falls into that too sure yeah of course
and did you ever envision when you when
you saw those films that one day you'd
be interviewing all the actors that he
worked with no was nowis no I definitely
wasn't thinking that way then I was I
was a model actress so I limited myself
in that respect I think and I have grown
up into who I should be but ya know I
definitely didn't think one day I'd be
sitting here talking about Quentin
Tarantino and sitting with those
fantastic people yeah what made you
decide to make the film and you'd had
already done a film about Richard
Linklater so was it hi-ho directed
Linklater with Michael Dunaway and we so
be I spend a lot of time in Austin so I
was familiar with more familiar with
Rick and his work because he kind of
runs that town you know there's a lot of
that I was an extra on the Newton boys
oh so when I heard that Michael Dunaway
was doing this project he was he was
kind of looking for a partner and I
and I happened to be at the right place
at the right time actually it was a
Kevin Smith interview that we met that
he was doing for Linklater so that's how
that happened it was very organic and
amazing and Michael has moved on to do
other things and left me to do kind of
you know move on with Tarantino on my
own but that's how that came to be it
was it was very natural and easy and
awesome so when you saw how much fun and
easy the process was with the Linklater
film as a being a co-director a writer
on it what made you think you know I
want to do this one and I want to do it
on my own well I I really I've realized
this as I've been talking about why I
decided to move on to this because it's
not something I really thought about you
know I just I was like oh I love this
I'm doing this but the part that I
really loved about it was finding out
things that are misunderstood you know
and either debunking or digging deeper
into so for example with the Linklater
what we learned is we were talking
people and even around Austin what I
would hear oh he's very laid back and
he's very easygoing and as we did these
interviews I was like he's not he's not
laid back in that sense like he's very
intense and those exactly what he wants
to do and I found that fascinating I was
like wow I was like this idea that
people have isn't who that person is but
let's show that let's like really show
that side of it and how that affects the
filmography and where things come from
so to move into Tarantino on my own I
think I was really driven by the
misunderstanding of his female
characters and and what I was here again
about Quinton was that he was very it's
very nice it couldn't very nice and when
you see him in interviews or the idea
that we have of Quinn nice wasn't the
word that would normally come to mind so
I was like what what is that you know
what is that where is that coming from
so digging into we're not even digging
into allowing people what I love about
this documentary the like not
interviewing the director and sitting
with people and his friends and
colleagues and just letting them go and
just discuss you're like oh that's the
real breath of Quinton that's what that
is that's where it comes from so and
obviously we'll get more into that but
that was for me really exciting and to
be involved with people that do what
they love to do and are really good at
doing like that's attractive no matter
what industry right somebody's really
good is it like um you know watching the
the fastest person on the planet like
you want to watch that race like it's
really thrilling to see people do what
they're really good at and Quinn's a
master of filmmaking so yeah I was
really excited to to move on into it on
my own in that way I understand you've
been a sales agent for some time you
have wood Entertainment yes okay at what
point did you reach out to Quentin and
say you wanted to make this movie how
was it and what was the day like when
you got the word I might have been in
the car but it was Linklater the
Linkletter dog had just come out I think
and I was ready to to move you know I
really wanted to to dig into Quinton he
was I think he was still in production
on hateful eight when we started because
he so couldn't wanted to see the link
later doc he's like oh who is this girl
you know right so I was like oh here's a
link you know they're like no windows
and watch links so weeds away for the
DVD to be printed because you know and
send him the DVD while he was shooting
and he took time to watch it which is
amazing but in uh like he just loves
films and that's just one of those
things that proves again how much he
does like he'll stop in the middle of
production and watch a film that's
pretty amazing
so he watched it and gave us his
blessing he said he you know he loved
that it concentrates on the filmography
and not being an expose you know like
that my interest is definitely not ooh
what's you know the the juicy stuff that
people don't know about Quinton that
that's not exciting to me and obviously
that showed in the Linklater documentary
which was great so he allowed us to keep
going or it allowed us to move forward
with with his dock but I remember
getting the information I was like oh
cool so I can go and there was probably
a half hour later where it's like
Quinton Tino watched my first piece and
liked it enough to say yes like that I
just got chills that was that was very
surreal I was and there's there hasn't
been another doc about him and I doubt
it's because of lack of trying from
shore other filmmakers you know so so
the slow realization of what that
actually meant like would I still can't
articulate I guess it's pretty amazing
feeling and how special I felt I guess I
was like wow cool I can do this he liked
my first film and ultimately when I met
him he quote you know how he quotes from
movies like he knows everything
like everything said so when I finally
met him he quoted a couple lines from
that Linklater doc oh wow any think I
was fall off my chair I was like oh my
god yeah but he's just a lover of film
like he loved all of it all of it
including my little Linklater doc yes I
suppose wondering is when you got that
call or where whatever it was the texts
that were you almost like oh no now like
this is really happening like that keeps
Gary okay that eventually came where I
was like this better be good you know
like I better do a good job I better
hold this carefully sure yeah but that
wasn't initial initial I was like okay
my thing okay cool move forward and then
yeah that carried through the whole
documentary I would say that feeling of
of holding it carefully it you know be
kissed because these people are sharing
really intimate details about their
special relationship with this amazing
director and that was a lot that was a
lot to care for you know so through the
entire process it was very much like
yeah how do I care for this individual
person and what they're saying and and
and pull out what's important to the
Tarantino conversation as a filmmaker
and as a person right that that feeling
never went away
that was a constant like hold of
responsibility yeah there is there's a
trust factor and then if you don't want
to break it because then they mean on
what the interview out or whatever and
it is a lot of responsibility even even
doing these it's just you know people
are willing to come and sit in front
yeah that's a lot tell you yeah I don't
think people necessarily get you
definitely give a lot of care to that
which is wonderful like I feel like I'm
good cans when when I sit with I want
people to feel the same way you know
it's like it's okay and if you say
something you're like oops I shouldn't
said that I'm not gonna go put that on
the screen right that's the big thing
that yeah you're not gonna go and try to
like spin it because it'll get more
right of reaction so right especially in
this this landscape that works yes
surely definitely and people look to
misconstrue and I think people are set
up to mister misconstrue so that it does
get more attention you know yeah
you